people who like boots people who don't
like boots making fun of boots why am I
here
all I'm just singing the Hawaiian troll
because people like when I did it last
episode welcome to the wah-wah I might
be editing this one as well that is true
Brad is not here Brad to died and Here I
am
Unni I need a video the same day guys I
don't want to add it this I'm already
tired god dammit
roll the intro Felix god damn I'm
[ __ ] yes I think I still have the
car I think it's illegal for me to drive
that car but we need a part two this was
a better time interesting hairstyle from
Marzia I wish okay I wish my cell would
go back to this look she look way better
nice try but you know what we want it's
so great to be part of a channel where
the entire universe just hates you it's
like people who don't like boots people
who don't like boots Here I am everybody
what you meant to say was people who
like peach and people who don't like
boots and trust me I'm starting to not
like you either pewds 65 million
subscribers going strong Felix reacting
to memes with might say Ibiza oh my god
it continues pewds eats a picture of him
right so he didn't complete it he wrote
me on Twitter saying no this is fake I
haven't done it yet so no Lego Star Wars
game boy it's coming guys it's got me
get an Alexa Alexa hello goddammit no
don't ever do that again
Alexa never do that again sorry I know
there you go you can check that one off
play his guitar okay all right okay all
right
this guitar has been in the background
in my videos for too long it's missing a
string and I just haven't been bothered
to fix it I can easily fix it if this
video gets 500 thousand likes I will
play des prés Ito on guitar [ __ ] as
promised next week okay okay
all right okay okay
what's up nine-year-olds bread and sighs
funny editing nine-year-olds felix thank
you so much
I made EPT pie propaganda poster okay
this is epic I like this I like this a
lot
YouTube me can you cast obsidian can't
wake I subset in yeah this videos
everywhere can you stop recommending it
to me stop it no one cares about our
soup the Indian what was that what was
that Felix super DM you alright let's
cool kids and crushes men have
girlfriends
legends have depression Alexa this is so
saying can we play dismiss itto number
five thousand five hundred and nine
there's no dis percy to 5500 and hey now
we can create this 22nd biggest country
in the world this is really cool finally
something positive on this Lawai i
wonder how many of those people are dead
oh my god reacting to his most popular
video reacting to his most unpopular
video you just got myself a video ID I
like you whoever did this very good Alex
ex ex ex ex ex ex ex okay alright would
you remember you left a pride one and
Brad two chained to the basement
without food it happens guys it happens
that's probably why I have to edit this
video
Brad one into laughing when they see
that PT by Ashley Eddie to his own video
but then sees how much everyone enjoyed
felix editing when yeah remotes yet so
again I guess you guys figured me out
huh
you figured me out yes I play minecraft
what are you going to do you
nine-year-old virgins you're fired
you're unable to work here again your
job and or my favorite you are promoted
to customer well done it's not bad memes
this week I have actually laughing Adam
I went to the highest mountain in Sweden
just to tipos and ret merch what an
absolute mad line
congratulations check out March only
available for more days okay the nine
year olds are getting younger
[Music]
hey guys I'm having some trouble with my
YouTube red membership
can you help we'd like to help could you
share more details about the issue we'll
look into it
I can't seem to find season 2 of scare
PDP can you Abe this is so great if this
video gets 5,000 likes I will leak scare
PewDiePie season 2 on dailymotion x'
everybody what is he really going to do
it mm-hmm 5 doesn't like soon you'll
find out
I met PewDiePie five days ago I got
roped into watching my 3 month old niece
while my sister got her hair done so
there I am sitting in the waiting area
of a hair salon with my knees and who
walks in but effing PT Pi himself I was
nervous as Sh
and just kept looking at him and he was
sitting there with his phone and waited
but was too scared to say anything to
him pretty soon my knees started crying
and I'm trying to quiet her down because
I didn't want her to bother pooch but
she wouldn't stop I was there I remember
this actually pretty soon he gets up and
walks over he started running his hands
through her hair and asked what was
wrong I reply that she was probably
hungry or something
so Pierce put down his phone picked up
my knees and lifted his shirt he breast
fed her right there in the middle of the
hair salon chill guy were really nice
about it would let him breastfeed my
knees again the Italian stereotype it's
true this history a lot of many people
pointed this out in the video 5 lies
that girls tell I'm fine I'm not jealous
I'm over him sure we can be friends I'm
poppy Harlow and I don't know my opinion
your two recommendations can you guys
upset in that videos always a paid to me
and I'm like WTF I don't even watch
stuff related with that ok I'm gonna I'm
gonna title this video and thumbnail it
exact
the same and I need you guys help to
trick YouTube algorithms and viewers
that that is what they're watching so
everyone common in the video is saying
wow that is epic you can actually cast
come on guys I need the views help a
brother I come on hard to swallow pills
the mine said it was good but we need to
stop making demands because it makes the
content even less original and the
subreddit sucks now it's only sucked
don't worry about it marzia host Lawai
it wasn't Brad here's edited his own
video no ass outro 20,000 up bugs you
always find something don't you you all
you sly little a Swedish guy that speaks
English with an American accent lives in
Brighton UK with his Italian girlfriend
and is wearing an American flag sir
and a Russian hat his neighbors must be
sooo confused mr. worldwide everybody
somehow I don't know how the most up
voted read it out of all time on this
read it happened last week and it's this
one and it has 30,000 upwards if you
sweat Face Swap this scene from
Incredibles 3 you get Casey nice and
Logan Paul great-great-great mean of
everybody thank you guys for watching
this video I had a lot of fun editing it
yep yeah I'm glad it's over thank you
guys for submitting all the memes thank
you guys for 65 million thank you guys
for buying the merch thank you guys for
becoming a joiner now for me I know I
always sound sarcastic but thank you you
guys are awesome I love that we have
this reddit that we can just share jokes
and ideas just know that I do appreciate
you even though you make fun of me even
though you do step on me even though you
spit in my face I still love you alright
this is getting too sappy goodbye good
if I were to say so when I'm taking over
you too
like it bro flips it up it's gonna keep
it with a pacing I'm never gonna switch
how's it going like this we wanna hit a
flow never stop run up in the city and
I'm never gonna fly tell me when I go
I'm like whenever I'm done with this
pass to Mike that Edgar